hi hello young Canadian legends thank
you
good to see you Jeff you just parsed
that so carefully well that's wonderful
no legend wonderful legends the
terminology that I say yeah it hurt for
sure yeah you are a super iconic
obviously we love you at et Canada let's
talk about this new role how good are
you at being bad oh I love it I love it
it's fantastic it's really not that hard
for me no yeah I mean would you just let
the floodgates open and to me one of the
funniest and most fun things that a
person can play in comedy is his
intelligence screwed up by ego you know
when that when when it moves over the
line into spiritual stupidity yeah you
know and yet he's the most intelligent
person in the world you know so it's
wonderful and it took me a couple of
weeks to prepare for yeah what's that
preparing like for you
it's just speed reading a lot of speed
reading okay actually my Google stuff
what's it like to be smart with the
whole cast in a lineup who do you think
would be the fastest who's the fastest
runner
oh my god fastest runner well it
wouldn't be me okay now my limbs are
going in every direction they all have
different ideas Sika said she would beat
you
Oh dad a devil definitely most of them
would watch them would because there's
also not caring I have that on my side
okay good to see you good to see you
Canada